okay so this is my spoiler free review
of the boys the new Amazon Prime series
that right now has a lot of buzz going
for it again in the comments below this
is based off a comic book so please do
not put any comic spoilers or spoilers
from the show in that matter save that
for my other video which is a spoiler
review which I'll have linked at the end
of this video so with the boys I had
incredibly low expectations one because
it's Amazon Prime which now is actually
getting really good in production
quality we're in the past they weren't
but it seems like they're investing more
money into their shows and this is one
of those shows you're watching you're
like wow am I really watching Amazon
Prime cuz the effects in it are like
movie quality so it's really cool to see
that and the other reason I was hesitant
was because this is produced by Seth
Rogen he's executive producer here and
the last time he touched a Garth Ennis
comic which was preacher which I loved
the comic started off good but then the
wheels fell off for me and I thought the
show got pretty bad and I was like oh
it's the same combo here can I trust him
with it but no it's it's ten times
better than anything I've even seen in
preacher so this got me on his good side
again and the story is great I have not
read the comics for the boys but I was
also hesitant a third thing because you
know you just had Umbrella Academy come
out there's so much superhero stuff but
it's not what you are expecting it is
like Watchmen if you like Watchmen but
it's a more up-to-date version and it
has a different angle to at where
they're going with it again I don't want
to spoil anything but the other thing
you gotta realize is when you watch this
premiere if you're not sucked in after
the first 20 minutes you're not gonna
like it but I most people will say
guarantee you're gonna get sucked in too
even if you're not in a superhero stuff
it's that type of show I think it has a
mass appeal that will just keep going on
by word of mouth here there's something
so shocking in the beginning that is
amazing and it's one of the best
premieres I've seen in the series in a
long time I think that there is some
incredible new face actors here and some
old face actors
and there is some questionable
performances which I'll get more into my
spoiler review but I think those can
only improve this show has a little bit
of a weird lull in the middle I would
say but overall it's a good pace and it
has a really good finale with a big big
cliffhanger and something that even is a
twist to comic readers of the book so if
you read the comic book there's a lot of
stuff they go off of it from and stuff
they don't so really interesting and it
appeals to I think everyone in this
sense don't get turned off because the
superhero show just give it a shot
because if you don't like that premiere
that's that's very hard to even believe
it's so good I think you'll enjoy it
from just that and get hooked in and
it's very with The Times like you can
appreciate in that sense too it's a lot
of stuff you haven't even seen touched
on in shows yet and they kind of put it
in there to their origin story from the
comics they insert it to make it more
current which is just genius and a smart
move by this show and yeah I mean so far
people are loving it they're already in
production of season 2 so I would highly
suggest watching this I would give this
season 1 and a total of an 8.8 really
good only complaints is more detailed
stuff again I'll go on my spoiler review
but a little low in the middle and a
little bit of question questionable
acting but overall really good stuff so
check it out it's a game changer for
Amazon Prime or if you're gonna watch it
let me know and please subscribe to not
miss any of my reviews of movies TV
shows and follow me at Steve are they
one for more of me and I'll see you next
time